damon and roy kavan
both retired fbi special agents
and respective senior team leaders for
the pittsburgh
and cleveland divisions of the evidence
response teams
on september 11th will ring
the bells of remembrance in their memory
lorraine g bay
todd m femur
alan anthony seven
mark bingham
deora francis bodley
sandy wall bradshaw
[Music]
marion r written
thomas e burnett jr
william joseph cashman
georgine rose corrigan
patricia cushing
captain jason m doll
joseph deluca
patrick joseph driscoll
[Music]
edward porter felt
[Music]
jane c folger
colleen l fraser
andrew sunny garcia
[Music]
jeremy logan glick
[Music]
kristin osterholm white
gold
[Music]
lauren catuzi grand colas
and unborn child
wanda anita greene
[Music]
donald freeman green
linda grondland
[Music]
richard j godagno
[Music]
first officer leroy homer
toshiya kuga
[Music]
cece ross lyles
[Music]
hilda martin
alaska martinez
[Music]
nicole carol miller
lewis j nackey second
donald arthur peterson
[Music]
gene hudley peterson
[Music]
mark david rothenberg
christine ann snyder
[Music]
john talignani
[Music]
honor elizabeth wayneo
[Music]
deborah jacobs welsh
please join me in a moment of silence
as we conclude this moment of
remembrance
thank you this morning
i am honored to introduce mr
ed root mr root currently serves as the
vice president
for the families of flight 93
he is joined on stage today by his wife
nancy ed's cousin
lorraine grace bay was a senior flight
attendant on flight 93.
those closest to ed know of his personal
passion for sharing the history of the
american
civil war as both an author
and historian he served on the jury
to select the winning design of the
flight 93
national memorial in 2005
and since 2006 ed has served on the
board of directors
for the families of flight 93.
throughout the memorial's creation mr
root
has served on numerous committees within
the flight 93 national memorial
partnership
ladies and gentlemen please welcome mr
edward
mr president this is trump
father mcewan secretary bernhardt
steve and my wife nancy
honored guest family members and friends
thank you for attending today's
commemoration
a common field one day a field of honor
forever all of us who have a certain age
certainly remember that september
morning
when a darkness enveloped a beautiful
late summer day
that changed our collective lives as the
days
passed and we tried to make sense of it
all some of us
as family members of the heroes of
flight 93
began to come to this place we came as
strangers
strange land we knew not each other
we knew not the members of this
wonderful community
on the first anniversary of that tragic
day
a large number of family members
gathered to commemorate
to remember we were housed and traveled
together in that first annual ceremony
and a convoy of buses at the moment
we're beginning
to know each other a little bit to learn
a little bit more about the men and
women
who share those last moments of life on
flight 93.
as we travel through somerset
shanksville we were surprised as traffic
stopped and law enforcement and others
stood
and saluted as our buses passed many of
us
were taken aback as we did not feel we
personally
deserve such honors this day we as
family members have been treated
by local state federal officials the
public at large with a respect
that is sometimes awkward we as family
members
do represent the heroes of flight 93
this is and has been our only goal to
honor
and remember them this magnificent
memorial
established unanimously by congress in
2002
dedicated to the proposition that all
who visit this place remember the
collective act of courage
and sacrifice of the passengers and crew
revere this hallowed ground as the final
resting place of those heroes
and reflect on the power of individuals
who choose to make a difference we thank
the national park service
and the multitude of volunteers and
friends
who relate the story of the 40 heroes of
flight 93
it has been 19 years but sometimes it
seems like yesterday
the wounds never truly closed completely
the memories of our loved ones linger
like a mist
or a soft breeze it could be a song
a special date a holiday an article of
clothes a photograph
a name and it all comes tumbling back
some of us have crossed over the river
and a new generation has joined our
family circle
it has been 19 years and those too young
or unborn on that fateful september
morning
come to this place an honor
to learn the realm of history is taking
over
from those of us who lived and suffered
through that day
the image of those rushing into the
flames in new york and washington
to save others the co-workers who helped
others at the risk to themselves
the men and women who rushed here but
found no one to save
it is our responsibility as a nation to
see that these actions are remembered
our work is not done continues
we've watched this memorial grow from
that common field we've seen the
multitude of items left by visitors
at the early temporary memorials some of
those items spoke with a logic that
leaded no
explanation a first responder a law
enforcement
badge some spoke of continuing service
and sacrifice
purple hearts combat foods infantrymen
combat badges
items armed with blood toil tears and
sweat
other items seem possibly out of place
except that visitors felt the need to
leave something of themselves
it might have been something found in a
pocket it might have been a child's
toy the heroes of flight 93 had two
elements that those on the other planes
and those on the ground in washington
and new york
did not possess they had knowledge
not a lot but enough they had time
not a lot but enough
they use that knowledge and they used
that time to develop a plan
and implement it they were unable to
save themselves
but they knew that unless they acted
many more would die
the men and women of flight 93 came from
different backgrounds and beliefs
they were mostly americans but also
citizens of japan
germany and new zealand they had one
very important
thing in common they all came from a
belief in a free society
those who embrace the philosophy of
terror have proven over
and over that they will die for their
cause
their cause is death they build nothing
they save nothing they produce nothing
the cause of the heroes of flight 93 was
to save life
certainly their own if possible but they
knew the cause was greater than their
own lives
it's been 19 years a lifetime for some
but a twinkling of an eye in the realm
of history
we must be diligent in protecting our
freedoms
we must remember we must honor those who
rushed into the flames of buildings
and into the cockpit of flight 93. thank
you
thank you ed for sharing your thoughts
today
and for your ongoing advocacy for the
families
and this memorial
i'd like to now welcome secretary david
bernhardt
the 53rd secretary of the united states
of interior which include
among many others the national park
service
and the united states fish and wildlife
service secretary bernhardt
has been a steadfast supporter to flight
93 national memorial
and directly offered departmental
support
to this special place to ensure the
final realization
and completion of the 40 wind chimes
at the tower of voices we truly
appreciate your support
mr secretary and thank you so much
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
secretary of the interior
mr david bernard
thank you superintendent clark the
department of the interior
through the national park service is
entrusted to serve as the steward
and the guardian of our national parks
our monuments and battlefields and each
site helps tell america's story
a rich and incredible story the places
we steward and protect
often highlight exceptional action
by incredible individuals but
none more so than this site
dedicated to 40 heroes our sites would
not tell the rich stories
without the dedicated employees of the
national park service
who i want to thank for working so
closely
with the families of flight 93 over the
last few weeks
to bring this 19th observance to
fruition
thank you last night i had the
incredible privilege
to join some of you to participate in
the chimes dedication ceremony
while there i had an opportunity to
listen
to patrick white and gordon felt
eloquently describe the incredible
reality
of 40 strangers from diverse walks of
life
thrown together by chance each
recognizing
the challenge they faced together
uniting
for a common purpose and a greater good
and then acting
with dispatch and resolve
against those who wished to attack our
great nation
all of these events occurring over such
a short
period of time is absolutely incredible
later as i walked with pat and gordon
up the pathway to the base of the tower
of voices
i reflected on the fact on a fact that i
have come to know with certainty
while serving in president trump's
administration and that fact is this
throughout my tenure i have witnessed
that this president has incredible
confidence in
and respect for the greatness of the
american people
this confidence in the greatness of the
american people has led him to find
unity
when it was not expected it has led him
to make stories
for our country when no one thought
possible time and time again
i do not believe anyone could believe in
the goodness of our country
and our heroes more and therefore it is
my tremendous
honor and privilege to introduce the
45th president of the united states
donald j trump
thank you thank you very much
thank you david very much
it's a great honor to be with you 19
years ago on this day
at this very hour on this field 40 brave
men and women
triumphed over terror and gave their
lives
in defense of our nation their names and
their stories are forever inscribed on
the eternal roll call of american heroes
today we pay tribute to their sacrifice
and we mourn deeply for the nearly three
thousand
precious and beautiful souls who were
taken from us
on september 11 2001
to the family members of flight 93
today every heartbeat in america is
wedded to yours
your pain and anguish is the shared
grief
of our whole nation the memory of
your treasured loved ones will inspire
america
for all time to come the heroes of
flight 93
are an everlasting reminder that no
matter the danger
no matter the threat no matter the odds
america will always rise up stand tall
and fight back to every 9 11 member
all across this nation the first lady
and i
come to this hallowed ground deeply
aware that we cannot fill the void in
your heart
or erase the terrible sorrow of this day
the agony renewed the nightmare relived
the wounds reopened the last treasured
words played over and over again
in your minds but while we cannot erase
your pain
we can help to shoulder your burden
we promise that unwavering love
that you sow want and need
support devotion and the very special
devotion
of all americans on that september
morning when america was under attack
the battle turned in the skies above
this field
soon after taking off from newark new
jersey
radical islamic terrorist seized control
of united 93.
other hijacked planes struck the north
tower of the
world trade center and then the south
had a fourth target in mind
it was called our nation's capital
they were just 20 minutes away from
reaching their sinister
objective the only thing that stood
between the enemy
and a deadly strike at the heart of
american democracy was the courage and
resolve of 40 men
and women the amazing passengers
and crew of flight 93.
donald and gene peterson were
grandparents traveling
to vacation in california
diora bodily was a student headed back
to college
richard wardango was returning
from celebrating his grandmother's 100th
birthday
lauren catozzi grincollis
was three months pregnant with her first
child
every passenger and crew member on the
plane
had a life filled with love and joy
friends and family
radiant hopes and limitless dreams
when the plane was hijacked they called
their families and learned that
america was also under attack
then they faced the most fateful moment
of their lives
through the heartache and the tears
they prayed to god they placed their
last calls home
they whispered the immortal words
i love you today those words ring out
across these sacred grounds
and they shine down on us from heaven
above
when terrorists race to destroy the seat
of our democracy
the 40 of flight 93 did the most
american of things they took a vote
and then they acted together they
charged the cockpit they confronted the
pure evil and in their last act on this
earth
they saved our capital
in this pennsylvania field the 40
intrepid souls of flight 93
died as true heroes their momentous
deeds will outlive us all
in the days and weeks after 9 11
citizens of all faiths background colors
and creeds came together
prayed together mourned together and
rebuilt
together the song god bless america
became a rallying cry
for the nation we were united by our
conviction that america was the world's
most exceptional country
blessed with the most incredible heroes
and that this was a land worth defending
with our very last breath
it was a unity based on love for our
families
care for our neighbors loyalty to our
fellow citizens
pride in our great flag
gratitude for our police and first
responders
faith in god and a refusal to bend our
will
to the depraved forces of violence
intimidation oppression and evil
in new york arlington and shanksville
people raced into the suffocating smoke
and rubble at ground zero the world
witnessed the miracle of
american courage and sacrifice
as ash rained down police officers
first responders and firefighters ran
into the fires of hell
on that day more than 400 first
responders gave their lives
including 23 new york city police
officers
37 port authority workers
and 300
new york city firefighters today we
honor their extraordinary sacrifice
and every first responder who keeps
america safe with us today is david
demato
a retired chicago police officer
and a current officer of the navy
reserves
on 9 11 he drove from chicago to ground
zero
as david says while the sights and
smells of working at ground zero will
forever be
etched in my mind what is more profound
is the way this country came together
afterwards
the police officers and firemen were
revered as the heroes
they truly are the military was
appreciated
in a manner not seen in decades and
common people
found new meaning and values like
friendship
kindness and selflessness
thank you david such beautiful words and
thank you to
every member of law enforcement who
risks their lives
to ensure our safety and uphold our
peace
this morning we also remember the 183
people who were killed in the attack
on the pentagon and the remarkable
service members who crawl
straight through the raging blaze to
rescue their
comrades we express our undying loyalty
to the nearly six million young men and
women
who have enlisted in the united states
armed forces since september 11
2001 more than 7
000 military heroes have laid down their
lives since 9 11
to preserve our freedom no words can
express
the summit of their glory or the
infinite depth
of our gratitude but we will strive
every single day to repay our
immeasurable debt
and prove worthy of their supreme
sacrifice
america will never relent in pursuing
terrorists
that threaten our people less than one
year ago
american warriors took out the savage
killer and leader of isis
al-baghdadi soon after our warriors
ended the brutal reign of
the iranian butcher who murdered
thousands of american service members
the world's top terrorist kasim
solomani is dead
here in shanksville this community
locked arms and hearts
in the wake of tragedy with us today is
chuck wagner a heavy equipment operator
who lives just a few miles away very
soon after the attack
chuck helped search for the black box
he was so changed by what he experienced
that he joined with several members of
his church to become what they call
ambassadors for the 40 men and women on
flight 93.
chuck and his neighbors learned about
each person cared for their families and
each day rain or shine they took shift
standing vigil over their
final resting place long before this
place was a national
memorial back when it was marked by a
simple wooden cross
chuck and his fellow ambassadors were
always here waiting to tell visitors
about those we lost
19 years later chuck says his life is
devoted
to three things his family his church
and preserving the memory of the men and
women
of flight 93. to chuck
his wife jane
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you very much
to chuck and his wife jane thank you so
much for
being here and to the over 40
ambassadors with us today
please stand and receive america's
thanks
and this is a very deep thanks please
so
thank you very much also with us is
marine veteran jason thomas from long
island
on september 11th jason had just
retired from the marines but he
immediately put back on his uniform
and raced into the nightmare of ash and
debris
at ground zero he found a fellow marine
dave carnes together they began to call
out
united states marines united states
marines
if you can hear us yell tap do whatever
you can do with the united states
marines
soon they heard a shout for help two
police officers were trapped beneath 20
feet of rubble
jason and dave dug for hours on end
knowing that
at any moment the wreckage could come
down on them
crushing them alive at one point someone
told jason to stop
jason replied i'm a marine i don't go
back
i go forward that day jason helped save
the lives of those two officers
for years jason said nothing about what
he did on 9 11.
he did not even tell his five children
but when he saw a rescue recounted on tv
he decided to meet those officers one of
them gave him a gift
what religion you were it didn't matter
we all came together
to help one another i die for this
country
i die for this country jason thank you
very much for bearing witness to the
character of our nation
jason thank you very much
thank you chase the men and women of
flight 93 were mothers and fathers
sons and daughters husbands and wives
nothing could have prepared them for the
dreadful events of that morning
but when the moment came when history
called
they did not hesitate they did not waver
40 towering patriots rose up took charge
made their stand turned the tide and
change
the course of history forever our sacred
task
our righteous duty and our solemn pledge
is to carry forward the noble legacy of
the brave souls
who gave their lives for us 19 years ago
in their memory we resolve to stand
united as one american nation
to defend our freedoms to uphold our
values
to love our neighbors to cherish our
country
to care for our communities to honor our
heroes
and to never ever forget
thank you god bless
9 11. we'll never forget god bless you
all
and god bless america thank you very
much
mr president thank you so very much for
those moving
and inspirational words
as we conclude here this day
together we do indeed remember and honor
the 40 passengers and crew members of
flight 93
in this special and unique ceremony
as we go our separate ways may we carry
the memory
of how they came together
on that day to make our nation
and world a better place
for all
at this time i would like to ask all in
attendees to remain in their seats as we
prepare
for the ceremonial wreath laying
i would ask that the flight 93
ambassadors
and dignitaries remain seated
immediately following the wreath-laying
ceremony
to allow time and space for the families
of flight 93 to walk to the wall of
names
and through the ceremonial gate to the
sacred ground
once again thank you all for joining us
today
to honor the memory of the passengers
and crew
of flight 93. thank you
you
you
okay
you